on peut pas opposer le cinéma comme
marché où le cinéma comme produits
audiovisuels ou le cinéma comme
industries culturelles qui produirait
des contenus versus quelque chose qui en
serait complètement détachée qui serait
le cinéma comme art qui ne passerait pas
par des circuits marchands qui ne
chercherait pas à faire d'entrée salles
et terrains donc déjà cette opposition
elle tient pas sur le plan esthétique
elle tient pas sur le plan économique
elle tient pas sur le plan sociologique
elle tient encore moins sur le plan
historique si on refait un peu
l'histoire du cinéma
justement comme art populaire il faut
pas non plus opposé le questionnement
économique et le questionnement
esthétique pense qu'il faut absolument
sortir de cette polarisation justement
de la production cinématographique qui
est qui est autrement plus subtil que ça
et bien sûr que tout ne se vaut pas mais
pas intrinsèquement parce qu'on a décidé
aujourd'hui que ça c'était mieux que ça
et bien sûr que moi en tant que
spectatrice je partage un certain nombre
de hiérarchie et que je fais des
différences et que je ne prescrit pas
les mêmes choses à mes enfants mais si
on veut réfléchir un petit peu
scientifiquement ce qui n'est pas la
même chose que la logique quantitative
ou comptable on peut faire de la science
sensible qualitative humaines etc
je pense qu'il faut quand même se
départir un petit peu de sa hiérarchie
ou en tout cas les réinscrire qu'est-ce
que quand je ne sais plus je crois que
c'est matthieu le chevallier qui parlait
de burgers flix bon bah ça c'est un
chant rhétorique la culture pop corn le
burger la consommation la fast good
movie kutcher et ses terrasses et enfin
je veux dire on a ça depuis 76 et la
sortie du magnétoscope
donc c'est une rhétorique et réactive et
là par les plateformes et qui en fait
est une rhétorique d'opposition des
publics d'opposition des films je crois
qu'il faut plutôt justement travaillé à
ce qu'il rassemble ses publics et
caetera et moi je ne suis pas
particulièrement catastrophé de voir des
gens aller en salle ou des jeunes
allaient ans et avoir des mardelles ils
sont les salles sont assujetties à la
même tsa et sa finance les films
français pour vieux crâne le vieux vieux
crâne chauve et gris donc on a la chance
d'avoir un système aussi de financement
du cinéma le français qui permet cette
circulation des publics et des contenus
[Musique]